[Music]
let's go to brian in evanston wyoming
what's up brian
how's it going we are rocking on brother
what are you up to
oh i'm just driving along here trucking
excellent man so what's up dude
well i just had a question uh how do i
get over my uh hate and uh just contempt
for my ex-wife
yeah we got two kids together i wanna
i i would like to uh be at least
friendly with her but i mean we split up
we split up like over 10 years ago and
she's still basically making my life
insane
how's she making your life it's against
me
she's turning the kids against me she's
constantly trying to drive a wedge
between me and my current wife
and and it's just uh it's just really
it's not uh it's putting a negative
impact on my entire life
she's manipulative and vindictive i mean
she gets mad over
over my wife signing a permission slip
for one of the kids
it seems insane to me yeah
um
how'd your marriage end man
oh it ended bitterly bad she cheated on
me uh
you know and then she cheated on me
twice as with two guys as far as i know
and then uh i found out about the first
guy along like after we had already
split up
and she you know i found out about this
other guy
and and i you know that i mean it just
devastated me because we stayed married
another like three years after
after that that guy and and she i mean
she was able to look me in the eye and
lie to me for years
and then you know it's kind of a
bittersweet thing because
it was horrible but we got our second
daughter kayla out of it all right and i
you know i it's just
you know it's it's to this day i mean i
i it feels like i didn't get any closure
because she won't give manny yeah you
know she she just wants me to die alone
and and
uh miserable yeah
and she's doing her best to make it
happen
why
can i ask you a couple hard questions do
it
why do you give her this much power
like i don't know i get the like yeah
she's she's
raising hell with the kids that's hard
that just
we can talk about how to deal with the
kid's stuff that's hard man
but you are continuing to allow her to
you're choosing misery for some reason
and i don't fully get why tell me why
i don't understand i don't get it either
i i would love i want to be happy you
know i i don't
i mean like like
it's left this whole thing has left me
with just crippling self-esteem issues i
can't i can't even be fully open with my
wife that's right and she she she can
compliment me and i won't even i won't
believe it i don't believe it i believe
she's lying yeah to my face
and but here's the thing here's the
thing i'm gonna give you your power back
okay
i want to change your language too i
can't to i choose not to
and there's a reason why you choose to
not trust your new wife because you went
all in on somebody and they burn you to
the ground
right yeah
i've been with my wife for 10 years it
doesn't matter dude it doesn't matter
you're still hanging on to the first one
and more importantly you're not hanging
on to her as much as you're hanging on
to what's wrong with me
and until you can quote unquote figure
out what's wrong with brian
the truck driver who just wants to be a
good dad and just have a little bit less
sucky life
until you make peace with brian
your brain's going to continue to try to
solve for enemies that don't exist
you are giving a woman a decade ago who
hurt you
access to your present day life
and
why would i want to do that it's not a
matter of want it's a protective measure
until you get back in the driver's seat
of the truck you're moving down the road
in your brain will drive for you
until you sit down and own
oh this happened
and i'm not screwed up something was
wrong with her or maybe i wasn't the
husband i could have been
it was both hand often it's both hand
and now i get to choose what tomorrow
looks like and you haven't made that
step yet because you haven't grieved it
you haven't just sat there and sat in it
you've had to make peace with the fact
that she's going to be part of your life
because y'all created kids together
which by the way is also hard because
something good did come from her
right
and you have to own that she's not all
evil she's mostly evil but man she
created two beautiful little kids with
me
and so it's a hodgepodge of emotions
what i don't think you've dealt with
that a lot of people deal with when
they're working through infidelity
is you lost trust in brian
you don't think you're good enough you
don't think you look good enough you
don't think you're smart enough or i'm
just this piece of crap truck driver
probably could lose 40 pounds and fill
in the blank and you've created a whole
story about brian that's not true
and then you go through your life
looking for ways the world can back up
the story the narrative you've created
about yourself and the world's happy to
do that
if you just made more money if you just
look better if you just didn't do this
and your wife your ex-wife's happy to
throw some gas on that fire
yes yes you know what i mean
yeah
you have to make peace with brian
you have to begin to trust brian and
when you trust brian then you can trust
other people
because your brain is not even beginning
to do that
number one you got to choose
nope let me back up number one you got
to own reality and you haven't done that
your wife cheated on you period
your wife hurt you bad and she lied to
your face people are capable not all of
them but some people are capable of
incredible
dishonesty and and um
uh incredible disloyalty and it happened
to you you got hurt
you got to own reality and you probably
have to own some crap that you did along
the way right is that fair you weren't
perfect as a husband
maybe you were shoot maybe you were i
mean nobody's perfect i
but i mean you know i i didn't cheat on
her i didn't hit her i've support i've
raised our fam we raised our family we i
supported the family i don't know
what else i could have done different
maybe i'm emotionally unavailable i get
that from my wife all the time sure
all right so
i'll give you that there you go so so
and again i'll give you emotional
unavailability is a protective measure
because your body remembers hey we were
emotionally available once and it got us
killed
so let's put that away let's put that
away right
the sucky part about where you are is
the only way forward
is choosing
to possibly get hurt again that's the
only way
you i gotta choose to put myself out
there again correct
and right now you share a bed with a
woman who loves you and you're
completely and totally alone and you
know that and especially your body knows
that
and you're around two kids that you
absolutely adore and love and would do
anything for and they kind of look like
your wife and your body knows it and it
says danger danger danger and what you
have to choose is hey i'm going to start
trusting brian
and i can give you a couple of quick
tips and tricks on how to do that you're
probably not going to do them but i'll
i'll write them out for you okay the
second thing you're gonna have to do is
make a daily choice for about four
months
that my ex-wife does not get a vote in
my life
period
and when i run up against
bonkers things
like she's a rattlesnake and you keep
putting your hand in the bag getting
surprised that she that she bites you
that's just the way she is and so i'm
not trying to figure out a rattlesnake
it just is i'm just gonna put my hand in
the back
and so
my wife the step parent of my two
children sometimes have to sign a
permission slip and so
i know that she's gonna send weird text
and throw a hissy fit because that's
what she does
i'm not gonna allow that to ruin my day
i'm not giving her access to my day
and if she wants to throw a super fit
and cause i'll cut
that's fantastic i'm just gonna call the
lawyer and we'll get an amendment done
i'm just not gonna i'm not gonna fight
you
and there's something incredibly
empowering about looking at somebody
going
i i'm not i'm not gonna fight you
hear what i'm saying it's just a totally
different way of looking at the world
but first before you do any of that is
you gotta look at brian and say
yep we missed it
she was sleeping with a friend of mine
she was cheating on me with another guy
and for three years i knew something was
off and i didn't go with my gut and i
stuck it out and it still ended up in
ash and then find out
all right you gotta make peace with that
so that you can look at your new wife
and say for 10 years we've been married
and i've loved you but i didn't know
what that even meant
and i'm going to go all in and so i'm
going to have to practice being
vulnerable again because last time it
got me killed and the only way that you
and i can have a great incredible
recklessly lovely merit lovely marriage
moving forward as if i
risk again
and dude it's so freaking worth it man
it's so worth it brian
yeah that's tough to do it's a dude
i can't i can think of no tougher thing
right i can't think of a tougher thing
i can't
either
but if nothing else your little ones
deserve that man
because they here's the deal they feel
that gap and that tension
so let's talk about your kids real quick
you're playing a 15 or 20 year game with
them right now okay
and it's not going to
um
this is an mma match and you are going
to
do a lot of blocking and a lot of
pushing up against the fence
and a lot of foot stomps and a lot of
leg kicks you're not trying to knock
anybody out here you are just slowly
playing a long game here because your
goal is round four and five
okay and you're up against a superior
opponent in the short term which is a
wife who can throw grenades at you that
can say things like oh your daddy
doesn't love you you know what he did
and you can't do anything about that
nonsense
what you can do is continue to show up
and continue to show up and continue to
write your kids little notes
with their from their truck driver dad
to continue to do what you can to be at
the at their events to continue to hold
their face and look them in the eye and
say this house doesn't work without you
and i'm so glad you're my child say that
every day for two months and watch what
happens
they'll roll their eyes at you they'll
be like
and their physiology will change
ask them if you can read them uh
bedtime stories or even better yet make
them up together
and co incorporate that right so you can
play long games and what will slowly
happen is the kids are brilliant
they will slowly start to put together
oh she's crazy
because that doesn't make sense
and then one day when they're 17 18 25
33 they'll say hey whoa
you weren't the devil were you and
you'll say no and i loved you every step
of the way that's the game you're
playing right now okay
and that does not give you a terrible
game it's a it's it's it's the worst
game
it's the worst and i'm i i'm heartbroken
just guide a guy i'm heartbroken that
your wife your ex is doing this to you
but i'm not gonna give her one more
moment of rent free space in my head in
my heart
period especially when not one thing
she's doing is surprising me
yeah
like you know same same crap same stuff
all the time yeah it's like every time
you walked in to see me i just hit you
in the mouth like the 48th time you'd be
like quit hitting me and i'd say i hit
you every time quit walking up this
close you know what i mean at one point
at some point we're both at fault
and so i'm just gonna make that choice
i promise you brian
with everything i got
two guys sitting at a bar
over cheap beers and chips in case i'm
talking to you right now i promise you
your way forward
with telling your new wife
of a decade
i'm gonna try something different
and i'm gonna need you to help me and
we're gonna come up with a new language
on when i start withdrawing
um i'm gonna start saying out loud
um the story i'm telling myself is i'm
not really looking good and you're just
saying that and give her an opportunity
to say nope you do you look good
you know what screw it can i tell you
brian this weekend
i was with my wife and i was wearing a
shirt
and i like a
t-shirt
and i said hey we were out somewhere and
i looked at her and said hey
i don't feel like um
this is a good shirt for me to be
wearing like it just feels bad on me
and she said you look good
and my first thought was no i don't and
then my second thought was i trust you
i'm still practicing this and i haven't
had near the hurt you've had okay so i
want you to know you're not crazy we're
all figuring this out it's how are you
going to risk that relationship because
my wife could have said yeah never wear
that shirt again you look terrible she
could have said that and then i just
wouldn't worn the shirt anymore right
develop that language with her a couple
of things for you this is gonna sound so
cheesy man but when you're out over the
road are you over the road you go home
every day
i get home every day okay
then before you get out of the car i
want you to go to walmart and get
something for six bucks and it's gonna
be a small little black or red or green
little notebook that's leather bound and
i want you to put it in your truck
and write a few things about the day
down into them
but a couple of these things are i'm
grateful for
and i am a good dad and i'm about to go
in and be a great husband and i want you
to get your truck and go inside your
house but i want you to start practicing
writing this stuff down you got to get
out of your head and out of your body
and let your body begin to heal
okay
and there's going to be ups and downs
and sideways and forwards
the goal here is human connection human
touch forgiving brian
and dude you gotta go risk you gotta go
risk and i hate that for you man but you
got to the only way it's the only way
forward
okay do you love this new lady you're
with
yeah
a lot is she cheating on you it's way
better than the old one
like
like she's a set of tires that's
fantastic better than the old ones
um now she did she'd be gone before she
told me
[Laughter]
hey it's probably not going to happen
man
i think this lady loves you
and i know he doesn't reassure me quite
a bit there you go
and so um
you may not believe brian and you're
gonna have to practice believing brian
and learning to trust brian again
um you put that guy in a box for a long
time
start practicing trusting her
and say i believe you and i'm gonna drop
my shoulders and exhale i'm going to
choose to believe you
and maybe you tell her
you can hurt me because i'm going all in
on you again and i should have done this
10 years ago and i'm sorry and i've been
protecting myself from more hurt and
more hurt and in the process i built
walls that keep me from you so i'm going
all in and look at her and say
please don't hurt me
i'm going all in on you
please be there with me ride or die till
the end
i'm all in
you